como a los monos para mí el momento más
maravilloso de la moda es como
espectadora la alta costura en su lugar
de espectáculo es un lugar de expresión
ilimitada que no está ligada solamente a
su valor comercial sino que es realmente
una forma de expresión artística
[Música]
y nunca había sido ha sido excepcional
la artesanía involucrada están
exquisitas lleva tantas horas y creo que
esencialmente en estos tiempos saliendo
del cómic es importante poder celebrar
ese tipo de trabajo que hizo la gente y
su contribución saben cuando vengo a un
desfile en francia siento que estoy
llegando al corazón de francia y además
maria grazia siempre subraya ese mensaje
creo que va a hablar de ucrania así que
me hace mucha ilusión estar aquí y
formar parte de eso
y así es para su colección de alta
costura dior otoño invierno 2022 maria
grazia chiuri evoca a ucrania como lo
hace al confiarle al artista
multidisciplinar de quien ole se
atrofien con la tarea de ocuparse de la
instalación escénica
nos dijimos que teníamos que hacer algo
optimista
dada la situación era muy difícil
concentrarse
con todas esas noticias horribles de
muchas y de otras ciudades
pero al menos fue la decisión correcta
celebrar la vida y no al resto
va a quedarse en parís o va a volver a
ucrania
no mañana vuelvo a ucrania
la obra de olés ya trophy menco es una
mezcla de fotografías pinturas y
bordados en referencia a las prendas
tradicionales ucranianas para construir
su colección maria grazia chiuri también
se basó en un símbolo conocido por todas
las culturas el árbol de la vida
pienso que esta idea está muy cerca de
lo que hacemos con el bordado
esa idea que encontré y me conmovió en
el programa que hay en europa sobre un
nuevo bajas
creo que mezclar todos los diferentes
conocimientos es posible en la costura
no es muy experimental
hicimos otros vestidos con detalles que
probablemente no son muy visibles en la
pasarela
pero donde renovamos el viejo smoke pero
no se hace cosiendo sino con la técnica
del niño antes
esto se hace en nuestro taller de parís
que es magnífico y se trata o se pisa el
vestido
y después con el mignon se tienen que
hacer todos los pequeños agujeros para
hacer el smoke
está entre la construcción y el bordado
también la costura es un territorio
donde puedes experimentar lo que quieras
y eso es magnífico
estuvo hermoso estuvo muy hermoso
innovar aguantar a toda la costa en
tiempos de crisis se expresa de forma
diferente según lacasa jean paul gautier
no está activo desde enero 2020 pero sus
talleres ahora dirigidos por el grupo
español puig siguen produciendo en
asociación con diseñadores externos
encargados de interpretar el a del john
gotti después de la japonesa chitose ave
y el belga clean martins ahora es el
turno del francés director artístico de
balmain oliver gusta va ser increíble
creo que son dos mundos que realmente
merecían encontrarse ambos son hombres
que realmente aman los cuerpos de las
mujeres ambos hacen arquitectura con los
cuerpos de las mujeres es la mezcla que
había estado esperando
es histórico es un momento increíble
para olivier estoy muy feliz por él
por lo que está sucediendo con john paul
quien le pidió ser parte de este
proyecto lo que quiero decir es que
estoy muy feliz por él porque además es
un joven es la unión de dos mundos
diferentes mezclarlos de una manera
perfecta así que me siento muy feliz por
ellos y sé que va a ser un gran éxito
[Música]
creo que hoy fue una carta de amor y
respeto por todo lo que él hizo era un
monólogo en el que yo le hablaba a él
porque el handball no quiere
influenciarme mi colección pero era yo
quien intentaba hablar con él y decirme
qué pensaría él de esta colección de
cursos hubo algo particularmente difícil
las obras muchas horas en cada prenda
pero mucha pasión mucho amor y el
increíble taller que me apoyó hasta el
final no tuviera dificultades
estuvo fantástico debo decir que
realmente tomo mis códigos y muchas
cosas que he hecho pero lo transformó a
su manera aportó algo más no es sólo
copiar para nada al contrario es como
una base una fuente y luego hacer algo
diferente con eso braun estuvo genial me
encanta lo que hace y tiene mucho
talento y lo hace con humor al mismo
tiempo con mucho humor eso es algo que a
veces falta pero no esta vez aquí puso
un morro
fabulosa alta costura que casi nos hace
olvidar que estas prendas solo los
usarán unos pocos privilegiados pero que
influirán muchas creaciones más
asequibles